uma mala aqui a galera uma fortaleza
agora o show jonas político não luto e
fizeram de mim porque eu gosto e cheiro
de mulher no cu
o arroz é mais um que vem
ele foi o responsável pelo gol que
mantém pelo churrasco dentro do boxe
gente vai mais além e vale o terreno
porque acho que alguém está machucado
mas vai ficar falando com o papel
sintético do passo da copa com as pragas
da cultura de paz não é tão nosso na
casa no bairro bom porque achavam que a
questão estava na casa da costa mão e aí
galera neste campeonato bom vocês já
estão aqui fortaleza a galera estou
muito feliz estou muito feliz eu
consegui conhecer o eduardo sterblitch
eu não sei eu não sei como é que é pra
vocês eu não sei qual é a relação com o
hino que vocês têm não sei qual é a
relação com a pessoa que você admira mas
eu com ele acho que ele tinha todas as
pessoas que têm algum refer já faz
milhões de vezes não quero falar com
duas pessoas que tenham como referência
um novo jeito que eu em cena por outono
paulo a pé até o ricardo ficou da vida
conheci ele teve a oportunidade de
conversar com ele eu sei que você está
esperando algum vídeo tão esperando que
eu quero gravar alguma coisa com ele mas
não gravei porque eu estava com uma das
pessoas que eu tomo como exemplo em
qualquer coisa a fazer que eu não queria
perder meu tempo pedir tal olhar para a
câmera para falar eu vou falar que ele
não pretende mais conversar com ele e
ele me deu muita atenção e me deu muita
atenção e ele já me conhecia através de
uma família que vai todo show deles vai
o pânico e tal mostrou que eu faço pra
ele porque fiz pra cá e aqui em
fortaleza também fez encontro de fãs e
eu ganhei presente vou mostrar pra vocês
todo mundo sabe que eu amo lúcio é este
aqui é pt
totó também ganhei esse jogo sentindo o
senhor piersilvio mentiu foi a nicole ea
sara e também tem esse sá pinto ao
belenenses apitou bem este coelhinho
também que ganhou ganhei eu ganhei esse
coraçãozinho também esse colchão mais
fofinho idoso é um porquinho é também
ganhar pedrina dos lixões ou a casa do
pão olha só o que eu ganhei eu venho
frederick a mulher não conseguia
entender e me nem outras coisas bem 161
filtro do sonho de uma cartinha que
também caía uma apostila e aí galera que
assistiu canal adora essas categorias
que em alagoas no campo hoje entrego
tudo isso porque assim como é importante
pra mim eu quero que seja importante
para você eu aprendi contigo que sempre
podemos tirar um proveito de alguma
situação ruim que aconteceu obrigado por
tudo e todas as lições de vida e por
toda a felicidade proporcionada toda
lágrima que transformou um sorriso não
dá pra colocar tudo o que eu sinto até
porque meu amor demais então peço a deus
que dê força a todos os dias pra poder
continuar porque eu sei que não é fácil
enfim eu amo você e esse ponto sempre
você é doido é por isso que eu amo carta
eu amo cara que só de saber que a pessoa
para o assim à pergunta a pessoa perder
o seu tempo escrevendo aqui ó saber que
a pessoa perdeu tempo que a pessoa parou
assim para escrever uma coisa pra mim tá
eu me sinto muito especial porque é uma
pessoa que eu amo tanto fez presente que
eu ganhei eu amo todo esse sonho só o
menino que a família é grande 96 anos
aqui toda ok a família grande aqui ok a
família grande e quina morte a família é
lotado e nokia disse que o canal suíço
disse que o canadá gostei
é
foi meu jesus
o
não vai mais uma vez
e esses usos e os presentes recebidos
fãs aqui de fortaleza a gente pensa
encontro de fãs foi show muito bacana da
hora muito obrigado a cada um que foi lá
na verdade encontra dos fundos só
apareci lá e agora quero lançar um
desafio pra vocês no instagram todo
mundo comenta vem para ronaldo em manaus
é favorável a nós no meu facebook evento
a são luís em para goiânia vem para são
paulo no meu twitter para campinas vai
passar uma dor vai para a sede todo
mundo quer cavar guga então agora vou
fazer a parada eu vou aqui é o seguinte
você vai no twitter agora você vai
colocar a hashtag o windows ou vem pra e
coloca o nome da sociedade por exemplo
já foi três de votar hashtag o inversor
vem para teresina boca no twitter
a cidade que mais pedi pra ela e eu vou
que o negócio a ostentação ó tá tá tá tá
tá tá tá tá tá tá tá tá tá tá tá uma
coisa pra vocês vocês que estão no
facebook estão vendo isso no facebook e
já pode curtir essa publicação que
possui efeito não se quer dizer que ela
clique em curtir que você já me ajudou
muito e você está aqui no youtube você
vai ficar em gostei se você está no
twitter você vai dar rt na publicação
mas só isso já me ajuda muito é isso aí
muito obrigado muito obrigado desse
vídeo e é isso aí
muito obrigado entanto aí não era sério
porque gostei vou ficar muito triste
ei
hum
é o tchan
ficando gostei pra nós